President Eisenhower seemed the picture
of health in these films made in Denver
just before his sudden heart attack
nearing the end of his work in play
vacation the President appeared rested
refreshed and an unusually good spirits
stricken at the Lafayette Street home of
mrs. Eisenhower's mother the president was
helped into a car in the early morning
hours rushed along the street to the
Fitzsimmons Army Hospital and placed in
an oxygen tent in an eighth floor suite
meanwhile leaving Washington for Denso a
press secretary James Haggerty and Colonel
Thomas Mattingly a heart specialist from Walter
Reed Army Hospital in the Denver church where
he worshiped in churches and synagogues
all across a shocked nation Americans of
many faiths and many creeds United in one
prayer a speedy and full recovery for their
president though the heart attack was not
severe the fear of complications weighed
on the hearts and minds of the people
leading the church goers in Washington
was Vice President Nixon facing grave new
burdens in the fateful days ahead pledging
a continuance of Ike's program summoned to the
hospital for an emergency consultation a famed
Boston heart specialist dr. Paul Dudley white
declared prospects were reasonably good for the
president's complete recovery also arriving
was Major John Eisenhower staying in a room
across the hall from his father and anxious
vigil as America waited and prayed and hoped